hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren vor zwei Wochen habe ich dieses
Video hier hochgeladen indem ich meinen
privaten snapchat Account öffentlich
gestellt habe dann kam eine Menge Snaps
an wenn ihr nichts abgestürzt ich muss
dazu Apple gehen es rebooten lassen und
jetzt
machen wir genau das gleiche noch mal so
sieht mein snapchat hier gerade aus also
es sind schon paar Snaps eingetrudelt
und ich würde sagen wir öffnen noch mal
direkt den ersten von Richard
okay gleich sind die Mädels aber ein
bisschen sympathischer von da schauen
wir uns mal von Lisa an kommen gerade
vom HSV Spiel echt beschissen chillig
00 haben die gespielt ne die werden auch
dieses Jahr wieder nicht aufsteigen
schauen wir uns allerdings jetzt mal den
snap von Jan Knobloch
Emma schickt mir ein Video in dem sie
sagt
lecker für die Protein ja wer kennt
nicht wenn man das Eis einfach für die
Proteine ist mal schauen was mir die
Laura hier finde
ST natürlich
Sprachen lernen allerdings würde ich
sagen sollen wir jetzt mal irgendwo nach
ganz oben und klicken einfach mal random
hier den step an
es ist eine Mischung aus Knast und
Fußballplatz Nele schickt mir ein snap
von
[Musik]
ist der Freund Emily Dinosaurier schickt
mir Alkohol
Sandra bist du's halt's Alicia
kann man irgendwie seine Community
tauschen Dennis schick mir ein Video und
sagst
dafür
bin heißt nicht dass ich hier bin habe
das jetzt kapiert alles unter Teppich
krass ich wusste nicht dass ich mit dir
am snappen bin allerdings würde ich
sagen schauen wir uns jetzt mal wieder
ein paar Bilder an die mir gefällt
werden ne wir müssen uns ja nicht nur
Videos konzentrieren Lilly arbeitet bei
McDonald's
sagen eigentlich alle McDonald's
Mitarbeiter in Deutschland das gleiche
dieses herzlich willkommen bei
McDonald's Ihre Bestellung bitte
es wäre doch viel cooler wenn die mal
andere Sprüche auf Lager hätten Martha
schickt mir einen snap Fett ich will
immer den obersten snap öffnen aber es
kommen die ganze Zeit irgendwelche neuen
rein so dass ich dann irgendwie was
anderes wieder öffnen klick jetzt
einfach mal ein bisschen kreuz und quer
hier haben wir was geht ich liebe deine
Streams danke schön fürs Kompliment Kuss
die haben wir halli hallo Luca ich habe
einfach zweimal von dir geträumt mein
Beileid war glaube ich ein Albtraum du
und Sandra nee das sind zwei Katzen
fetter Einhorn Jonathan fetter Einhorn
schreibt hey äh hier sehen wir mich an
Mario Kart Stream hier sehen wir
du kleiner Sohn Joelina Arsch
menschlich gesehen ziemlich abstoßend
meine Story ist halt noch seit fünf
Minuten Online ne das ist jetzt alles
wieder am abstützen gleich
ey
for real 90% zu mir gesendet werden sind
mit Filter Lucy schick mal ein snapf
sind jetzt gemeldet wegen Cybermobbing
Natascha oh mein Gott
Emilia schickt mir hey du da du stinkst
also
was ich heute auf jeden Fall lernen ist
dass meine Community nicht nur aus
Menschen besteht sondern auch aus
Blaubeeren und Fischen ich würde es
allerdings sagen dass wir mal wieder so
ein paar Snaps nacheinander öffnen
sondern fangen wir direkt oben an habe
gerade in meiner Hose
die sind schöner als du diesen sogar
schon am verrecken
können wir alle mal diesen emoji
kommentieren unter diesem Video wir
machen diesen emoji jetzt cool
allerdings würde ich sagen dass wir uns
zum Ende des Videos jetzt mal ein paar
Snaps auf die schneller anschauen NICI
allerdings meine Damen und Herren zum
letzten snap den wir heute öffnen werden
und zwar ist es dieser
ich weiß wieder warum ich mein snapchat
privat gemacht